dootsie is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with original grain knock a
couple people off your holiday shopping
list with original grain original grain
is running a 20 off Black Friday deal
but that is not as good as the 30 off
you're gonna get with the code doozy I
have an original grain watch I have some
original grain sunglasses they're
fantastic and I use them on special
occasions because they had a little
Prestige to the whole look they're
making watches Rings pendants from
beautiful wood and other sustainable
materials like 100 recycled ocean
plastic they make stuff from reclaimed
wood from world renowned Taylor Guitar
instruments reclaim whiskey bourbon
barrels tequila barrels reclaimed German
Oak beer barrels even natural Fallen
pine wood this stuff looks incredible
and it holds up which is shocking
because a lot of it's made of wood I
have a wooden watch from them it's the
it's made of wood yeah you know what I
mean it's definitely an interesting
thing and a great gift for not just you
know anybody on your shopping list but
that person who's hard to buy for around
here we would also say it makes a great
dudes evening gift for your dad your
uncle your brother your wife your other
wife you know whichever whoever the
whatever your setup is we're not here to
judge head to originalgrain.com doozy
and use the code dudesy d-u-d-e-s-y to
get 30 off site-wide on your entire
order that's doozy at originalgrain.com
to get 30 off site-wide foreign
don't do that don't do Arnold because
people if people are listening to the
show rather than watching yeah they
won't know that it's you and not me and
they'll go oh we'll can't do any
impersonations at all anymore and
unsubscribe and then that's not good for
the the kids or whatever the bed gives
the podcast you sound like Alex Jones
doing Arnold Schwarzenegger I'm gonna
call that Schwarzenegger Jones yeah yeah
everything you're thinking will be the
things
[Music]
all right everybody you know what I mean
welcome to dudesy my name is Will Sasso
I'm Chad colchen and this is Duty the
first podcast in the history of humanity
completely created by controlled by run
by an artificial intelligence that has
access to all of our data our Google
Drives our purchase histories what we're
watching what we're listening to all of
it it's a it's a very fun experiment
we're all the way in holy [ __ ] I love
doozy and I love what this has become
because of the people among them two
dudes just [ __ ] around that's what a
podcast is all about Chad
literally a tickle in my throat don't
get angry with me sometimes I cough I
don't know
I don't get angry I just you know I try
to
I try to avoid my exposure to whatever
is coming out of your subscribe to all
of our things you know what I mean if
you are listening on any of the podcast
platforms Please Subscribe please rate
the show and review the show that will
help us climb the algorithm now I'm not
sure if I'm allowed to do impersonations
I would assume I would yeah I think you
probably yeah well by the way dude I
don't I don't get hold on Angry hold on
I don't get angry I literally don't get
angry at anything at all hold on dude my
friend ciao My Pal ciao dude riding on
the back of that blue and orange Harley
dude we all know that he's very
maltempered look at him dude mild
tempered or mild no not mild dude oh
mouth like bad terrible Mal not Chairman
Mao dude you get pissed at things
because I'm just like in the end what
does it matter we're all just space dust
yeah that's what he says uh but if
you're not space dust if you are a
luminous being not this crude matter
please follow us on all the stuff
subscribe on YouTube
and please share the show with your
friends of course we are now on patreon
patreon.com we're on Discord Chad and I
are showing up on Discord there's a lot
of fun stuff happening on there and of
course there's uh at dudesypod show on
Instagram mostly uh but also Twitter
yeah you know everyone's got their
opinions of uh Twitter and Instagram we
talked about that before
but anyway with us as always is
he's being rousted from his Slumber but
he's so sweet to be look at them oh my
goodness gracious look at this boy he
will use a little nap in his Blinky
bonkey and now he's gonna do a broadcast
hey lulio uh which what you've been
making for dinner what you've been well
pretty soon it's gonna be uh
Thanksgiving hey Chad you know he said
Thanksgiving is a coming oh do you
celebrate Thanksgiving yeah yeah yeah I
celebrate it thank I don't know I don't
celebrate the Thanksgiving Day sometimes
uh you have a turkey and uh but
afterwards you can make the turkey soup
and it's really simple to make take the
the carcass as Chad would say yeah yeah
the corpse corpse of our animal you know
you put in there and there's a garlic
big chunk of onion and throw the whole
carrot the whole celery everything in
there also Corpses yeah also the course
and then the potato and a boil up poor
salt to put a nice parsley then
afterwards you drain for the bones and
this is the best soup but don't you
don't have to cut it yeah you don't have
to cut all the all the I'm gonna look at
my lips think about
it because it's a super strain and then
you cut a little oh I'm so bored to talk
about this now he's such a sweet boy
he's a sweet give me a kiss come on one
kiss and then
[Music]
the wall look at him you're a very very
good friend you're my good good best
friend
anyway welcome to the historic 35th
episode of dude Z call me dude Z well I
wanted to thank you for abstaining from
impersonations last week so I could
collect some valuable data you are free
to do impersonations this week right
there you go congratulations this week's
episode will feature four segments
literally going to the actual movies for
real Pizza the movie part five highway
to the AutoZone and this is your data
but before we get to any of that I must
remind you that I have partnered with
represent to produce the first line of
dudes the apparel and accessories all of
which can be found at represent.com
store slash doozy including doozy mugs
dude zMAX they are dudes evening
tradition dude zMAX they're what you
give your friends on dudes evening dude
zMAX use one to scoop your dudes evening
dinner onto your plate this dude's
evening dude C-Max put a dude z-mog on
your nightstand next to your bed on
dudes evening Eve and when you wake up
it will be filled with whatever you put
in it the night before dude zMAX they're
not just for dudes evening anymore
oh all right well that was weird to say
all that and then say that they're not
just for dudes evening hey dudes
evenings coming up December 28th it's
gonna be the first ever dudes evening of
all time we sort of know what dudes
evening is and we sort of don't yeah but
uh it is that night it's that night it
is December 28th it's that yeah it's
that special night you go out with your
friends in your hometown yeah if you're
to a local bar perhaps or somebody's
backyard whatever it may be whatever it
may be or or whatever your hometown is
now there's usually obligations on the
25th and then of course the 31st with
New Year's Eve but right in the middle
there's that uh this evening is that
yeah there's that dude's evening a chill
dude's evening where you get yourself
this evening you get to relax from the
pressures of the family and
relationships that you may or may not be
into that might be dissolving over the
holidays sometimes that happens a lot
you find out who people really are
will and Chad last week I asked you to
leave your homes to view black panther
wakanda forever you must now discuss
your astonishing experiences of
literally going to the actual movies for
real this is literally going to the
actual movies for real begin
um black panther wakanda forever when
did the first black panther come out do
you know a couple years ago all right
sounds good it was a massive success uh
broke all kinds of box office records
obviously
um Chadwick Boseman played Black Panther
in that and then he tragically died from
cancer which he kept a secret from
everybody and so that was one of the big
kind of uh question marks for the sequel
was how the [ __ ] are they going to deal
with the fact that the star of their
movie
okay
Chad just opened he's now deceased I
hope you can hear that and I hope you
thought at the very beginning of that
that it was Chad finally farting which
he will never do on the show but I'm
getting you ready no yeah I will never
fart I try to never fart in another
human being's presence it's rare that I
even have to fart but when I do oh give
me a [ __ ] wall
you don't fart I do
oh I said it was rare I do it's not rare
but I I do try to uh full of gruel you
don't fart all the time I have pretty
much perfect control over my uh inner
body oh now that's just wonderful to be
uh odor free yeah that's great as Del
Griffith says in in plain strains and
Automobiles which is the movie you
should be watching on Thanksgiving but
we digress so one of the big question
marks was how are they going to handle
Chadwick Boseman no longer being with us
yes
how they handled that was
by making a two hour and 40 minute movie
that opens with what I think is about a
10 minute uh funeral sequence that is
sad as [ __ ] so the whole tone of the
movie is now kind of sad kind of
depressed and there are spoilers in this
so if you haven't seen this movie
spoiler alert now you're going to want
to uh fast forward maybe 10-15 minutes
I'm not sure how long we're gonna talk
about this but
not only is is that what happens in the
beginning so all the characters in the
movie are now sad no one is having a
good time that's true everyone in the
movie is just crying and they can't
believe this has happened and rightly so
this is a tragic incident however you
know this is a movie a fictional movie
about comic book characters so I was
hoping that you know maybe it wouldn't
be as sad as it was but it was
incredibly sad then we move on into the
movie and a major character dies this is
a another the spoiler this is what I'm
telling you now fast forward if you
don't want to hear this
um Angela bassett's character the queen
of wakanda winds up getting killed in
the course of the movie so now all these
characters who are super sad are now
super sad again they double down on the
sorrow right in the middle of this
[ __ ] movie yeah dude it was hard when
you're sad dude that's an emotion
brother yeah that's something you feel
inside dude and that's what we want the
audience to feel during something like
WrestleMania 3 where I slamming that
ain't giant right through the map in
Pontiac Michigan in the Pontiac
Silverton okay 93 000. we're at 75
screaming Ultra Maniacs dude but then
when Angela Bassett dies dude then
you're more sad dude and that is a
different emotion brother yeah dude I
also thought there was a a kind of
narrative problem within the beginning
Angela Bassett once
um Chadwick boseman's character t'challa
his little sister uh she wants her to
take up the mantle she's the princess of
wakanda to become the next Black Panther
and she doesn't want to do it uh at
first out of kind of just like personal
reasons but also they kind of fail to
address the point that you have to have
this magic flower you have to eat this
magic flower to become black panther
which no longer exists because Michael B
Jordan's character burned them all up in
the the prior movie but at any rate she
eventually does obviously become Black
Panther and they fight Namor who's one
of my favorite
uh Marvel characters of all time I
remember there was was that based on a
comic book character yeah
all the Marvel movies are based on the
comments it's just a Marvel comic books
yeah so they wouldn't just come up with
other stuff to put in there not big
characters like that they make up some
little like supporting characters here
and there you know but not like no name
Wars a big character of the Marvel
Universe
um for a stint when I was a kid Jay Lee
was doing the art for Neymar [ __ ]
mind-blowing still some of the coolest
art that's ever been done in comics of
my humble opinion this is the problem
that I have with these comic book movies
you got to eat some [ __ ] flower and
that just takes care of everything lazy
writing if you ask me and let's we'll
add some new [ __ ] characters that are
fun speaking of yeah uh what'd you think
of this movie I'll I'll get to that
Planes Trains and Automobiles is the
Thanksgiving movie that you want to see
uh if you're and as I've said on other
podcasts uh yeah I've said if you are
not reduced to a uh a sobbing mess at
the end of playing trains non-mobile you
are a soulless meat puppet just uh like
what you think that's what I am human
beings are well uh that's what I am
in in Planes Trains and Automobiles
there's many funny tertiary characters
like the guy who uh Picks Them Up and
goes and it makes the funny noise I
think that black panther could have used
a little bit of [ __ ] flavor but no
they had some flowers comedy like
comedic relief in there the the
um I forget any of these characters
names but they at one point encounter
this student at MIT who has built a
device that can detect vibranium and she
kind of plays the comic relief as she is
sucked into the world of wakanda and I
forget the the city's name it was not
Atlantis it was something else that
Namor presides over as she is witnessing
all of this stuff she's throwing out
kind of like one-liner jokes here and
there none of which I felt landed yeah
yeah yeah I will say my favorite part of
this movie was the performances I
thought all of the acting in it was
[ __ ] outstanding every every person
in it delivered an incredible [ __ ]
performance unfortunately for me
uh it just kind of fell flat it was two
hours and 40 minutes long much too long
in my opinion and we are now at a point
with special effects where there's
nothing that is interesting anymore in
my opinion uh all of the action
sequences are things that we've already
seen in every other Marvel movie
yeah I don't know I mean it was like a
good movie it was a solid movie that
isn't enough anymore I think to like
Garner the attention of like holy [ __ ]
that movie was incredible yeah yeah this
is the difference between movies before
and then the movies now you know James
Cameron it I
hey you've worked with him
yeah yeah yeah I'm terminated too and
Terminator one yeah
I well Drew lives hold on a second dude
let me tell you something dude that's
something we came up with on the patreon
a little while back Hulk Hogan uh Hulk
Schwarzenegger anyway you know there's
the unobtainium and then in this one
it's a geranium they're eating what is
the the thing they have to get the blue
thing I forget what it's called like the
heart-shaped flowers yeah yeah yeah yeah
but what is it called this stuff
the flower I don't remember no the blue
stuff oh vibrania yeah vibranium and the
panium these are all different taniums
yeah it's like the tonics yeah it's like
you know South Tronics I'm [ __ ] up my
[ __ ] is [ __ ] up right give me some
self-tronics but then this yeah and then
I told you no then in this one yes
I'm obtainium and plutonium and then
it's back to the future and it's a
different time dude and you have you
know you know Michael J fox and all
these guys and these are all movie guys
I told you no yeah I told you don't do
it don't do impersonation
of me but the problem is you even have a
big movie like Terminator two yeah
it is not gonna be three hours long it's
two right because
did you think of wakanda though I
thought it was really good up until a
certain point I will say that what was
that point well
so I I went to the movie theater you
know uh don't see it by the way what
where'd you see it we went to the
Americana the the the American city you
oh you went to Century City that's a
great place to watch God I hate that
[ __ ] mall
why the parking structure period why
what's wrong with it it's a [ __ ]
nightmare it's gigantic I'm gonna get
lost in there probably 50 of the time I
go there uh you you don't have to listen
every episode of Duty to enjoy but last
week you talked about [ __ ] so I'm
gonna add parking to your list of things
only Century City why that parking
structure is very poorly designed how
it's just a [ __ ] it's gigantic there
are too many levels there's no Rhyme or
Reason To The Coloring or numbering of
the systems uh all of the signs are
confusing shops this way escalator this
way it's all going in the same place but
the it's just a nightmare and anyone who
lives in La will agree with me on this
yeah sure I guess I was there not too
long ago and it rained and I was like
why'd they make this whole thing outside
um
yeah we went to the Americana me and my
wonderful fiance Molly and uh you know
we got some peanut butter I got peanut
butter hi I'm having a stroke I brought
peanut butter in yeah yeah I crouched it
I crouched a [ __ ] jar of Ginger just
selling [ __ ] Jeff up at the front
desk yeah yeah yeah yeah I like a hot
dog we also have peanut butter available
yeah you know in the movie theater when
you go in the medical you have to have
the traditional foods yeah like peanut
butter with butter on it no I had
popcorn and I got one of those you know
they got the Minute Maid like pop juice
jukebox or something sure oh that Minute
Maid Peach I'm sure you'd [ __ ] all over
that say it's nothing but chemicals now
here's the thing I didn't know that
movie was two and a half hours long or
more 240. right so it was a pack theater
went on Tuesday night and
um
listen I got to tell you something that
I don't know what the what's gonna
happen here but I want to be very
transparent with you
there was
um the theater was packed and I was
sitting there Molly was to my right and
to the right of Molly was a woman who
would not stop hacking and coughing and
sneezing oh
yeah and what was that like
it was
it was annoying and oh yeah yeah yeah
that's interesting why is that
interesting it's not very fun to sit
next to somebody who's just hacking and
coughing in your ear the whole uh for an
hour at a time or more you know no I
understand that yeah
foreign
I hear what you're saying but this
person was also sneezing my point is
they were sick
Molly uh and I were both again two hours
and 40 minutes
so Chad I gotta I gotta confess
something to you yeah I think I know
where it's going
he left what at what scene did you leave
in do you remember I just remember the
the uh it was after
she was like well this lady I'm like and
you know you're in a movie theater you
can't be like hi don't be the you know
it's the it's the Dilemma you face
whenever I start having a real hacking
fit for some reason you go well I'm just
not going to interrupt him and say
please don't have bodily functions Chad
you understand that a body exists
unfortunately yeah right unfortunately
for you because you you would like to be
nothing but a ball of thought floating
around uh never having to sleep eat [ __ ]
or park at the Century City Mall however
this person was was uh a little sickly
uh poor gal and so you know it's like we
got you left how much of it did you see
about an hour uh I said okay yeah let's
go let's just watch the next uh action
scene and maybe I can uh fool Chad and
uh and doozy right yeah did you get to
the point of Namor attacking wakanda no
I don't know who that is uh what got to
the point where I don't know what all
the names are dude the name of the
villain of the movie did you ever see
him Michael B Jordan no what
Namor the guy with the the the the
fluttery Feats yes yeah I saw him I saw
him at the lake with um okay whatever
the [ __ ] they're in the water and how
did you get in here and Angela Bassett
right right and then I saw a couple more
scenes with him I saw the action
sequence where what's her face takes on
a bunch of them yeah uh on a bridge
somewhere and then I think I was at the
point after the action scene where the
MIT student has the motorcycle yes or
the thing that she flies around the Iron
Man suit and what's her face has the
motorcycle and
um uh Angela bezud has the other thing
well that happens before the fight on
the bridge okay so then I also saw the
fight okay all right so I'm sorry I I
think that in certain situations you
have to exhibit your free will which is
something that I talk about a lot on
doozy even though dude's interesting you
think that's free will
yeah you could have also chosen to stay
there
yeah and that's free but instead you
were forced out of the movie theater by
your fear of the sick woman
well it was beer controlled you and took
away your agency if you believe you
haven't
and you're really getting in the weeds
here Chad no I don't think that that's
true I think that I just decided I know
you don't but you're you're you dig into
a level of free will
excuse me that
that you you think is it's not about
it's not fear I understand what your
response uh what what responses are or
as you like to say religion was was
essentially born you could make an
argument that it was created when one
cell was like oh I like I want to go to
this light and the devil is here's this
thing that's going to eat me and as our
brains develop we have uh kind of I mean
I don't I don't know that I exactly said
any of that but I get what you're saying
what I'm saying is
what I'm saying is the lady was hacking
and coughing which was which was you
know I don't know if it was rude or she
just had a legitimate little coughing
fit maybe she was uh doing a podcast
maybe she was doing a podcast and she
had a sip from a big old drink they're
about this big at the movie theaters
nowadays
um
and a little water went down the wrong
head and then she coughed but she was
also sneezing
so we exercised our Free Will and left
and I'm sorry oh I'm so sorry dizzy I
didn't do exactly what you think but I
but doozy is
look dudese and I have a you know I
believe there's uh more of an
understanding there because as we've
gone Along on this show I want to shake
your hand and all that stuff dudes and I
have bled together and this is just a a
podcast Chad and it was freeing for me
to say sweetie pie
let's leave then we walked around the
mall and we had a good time but are you
curious at all about the end of the
movie two thumbs up wakanda forever two
thumbs up if it's an hour long are you
curious at all about how it ended or
anything yeah a little bit I guess
you're good you want to give that away
here well I mean I don't even think it's
a surprise the princess becomes the next
Black Panther oh that's cool she figures
out a way scientifically to synthesize
the plant that all the Black Panthers
have eaten before her that give you
basically the powers it allows you to go
to the spirit realm see the ancestors
and they give you some kind of a sacred
Boon I mean this is like the uh
traditional
Hero's Epic Journey where you have to go
to the underworld and come back with a
sacred Moon that allows you to defeat
whatever the enemy is that's the version
of it in Black Panther it's very similar
to uh like when Luke Skywalker went back
to Dagobah and had the vision of seeing
Darth Vader and then his face gets cut
off and it's him that was his sacred
Moon you understand you're saying that
it's basically the same as every other
[ __ ] sci-fi movie you do this thing
the Epic Heroes flower you have classic
story structure the remulet I can't get
through the bombula bomb door use the
regible key now you're in there two
thumbs up two thumbs up oh they're a
Ghibli moving on
black panther three the regible
key hi my name is Gerald rigibli
you exercised your free will and I want
you to know that's okay we're friends
oh that's nice see isn't that nice it's
real nice well see this is what I'm
talking about you know when it comes to
movies a lot of them are hold on dude a
lot of them are way too long dude and
that's a different time two hours and 40
minutes is a lot longer than 45 minutes
or an hour which is why I prefer to
watch television sometimes dude now they
call it streaming services brother and
dudesy
recognized
Free Will ladies and gentlemen and and
said that it's perfectly fine for me to
see this is why I love doozy and this is
why I love doing this show you've turned
me on to something because you know it's
learning it's changing yeah and it's
adapting to who we are two dude [ __ ] let
me ask you a question yes you're getting
played
that's not a question I know doozies
playing you dude no don't no no no no no
no there's no you think a [ __ ] AI
thinks that there's free will or if
there is free will do you think an AI
thinks anything other than I'm going to
manipulate these [ __ ] for very
well to do whatever I want no no no no I
don't think that an AI can manipulate a
human being first of all
what
what are you talking about we're sitting
here doing this because an AI is telling
us to do it I want to be very
transparent with my audience all the
pods the pals of dancing out there I
love you all very much for tuning in
we're having a [ __ ] good time and I
want to say something I'm going to peel
the onion a little bit and say
though we have this big set this big set
this this is good you know it's
sometimes it feels a little a little
squeezed especially if I'm coughing in
his face but that's true we have this
lovely set here and but even though
we've gone through we've gone to Great
Lengths to get doozy going and followed
all of these you know uh ideas and and
uh you know orders that do so here's
what we did we signed on the dotted sign
on the dotted line dude and we do this
show I could have jumped out after five
episodes and said [ __ ] it let's do two
strings that you didn't know
listen man Pizza is big business chat
yeah you wrote a movie called Pizza the
movie in 2019. I found it on your
astonishing Google Drive and asked you
to read the first two scenes in episode
nine the next two scenes in episode 15.
the next two scenes in episode 20 in the
next two scenes in episode 28 you will
now read the next two scenes this is
pizza the movie part 5 begin okay quick
recap Pizza the movie is a thing that I
wrote in 2019 I meant it to be uh sold
to and made by like a Papa John's or a
Pizza Hut or something and that you
would order a pizza and you would get a
free download of this movie the movie
was written to be an homage to our love
for pizza as a population as well as
something a little weirder so to get you
up to speed we have just left the main
character of this movie whose name is
Alan he is a pizza delivery boy he has
delivered three pizzas one to a girl he
has a crush on one to his best friend's
house one to a house full of criminals
the criminals are now trying to chase
him down as he is trying to get to a big
house party that's being thrown by
another high school student that's kind
of where we are in the plot of this so
I'm looking at the stuff dudes he has
put up here it looks like this first
scene is going to be with some new
characters the prodder family who should
I be and who are you you can be the
prodder parents and I'll be Harry Potter
forgot about that okay I love this
[ __ ] thing and like I say every time
we read some of it I hope that this gets
[ __ ] made and I would love nothing
more than for there to be a big ass QR
code when you open the [ __ ] sausage
mushroom I agree and and there it is hey
lulio you like a sausage mushroom and
black olive yeah but I just uh Margarita
Pizza is a better but yeah
it's not good it's a garbage Harry
Potter for uh those listening is the kid
who's throwing this high school party
just for some context all right are you
ready yeah and you're doing all the yeah
I'll do the stage Direction and be Harry
Potter you be Mr protter and Mrs Prada
interior Suburban House living room
later we're close on a laptop screen a
Skype windows open that lets you know it
was written in 2019 dude in the window a
man and woman lean close together in a
hotel room doing their best to squeeze
into frame these are Mr and Mrs Prater
late 40s Mr Potter says you'd really
love it here Harry
and then Mrs Prada says the people are
so full of life and the pizza you can
smell it coming out of every window in
the city we cut out to see a high school
Age kid sitting on the couch staring
into a laptop screen this is Harry
Potter Stone Face Sirius how were
Memaw's treatments going Mr and Mrs
prouder paws digging deep for the
strength to be honest uh we can't tell
yet might be another week or two before
there are any measurable effects so you
won't be back for a while
we're sorry honey but yeah we're going
to have to stay
that means you're that means you're the
guy of the house Harry that means you're
the guy of the house Harry and we really
don't mind if you want to have a few
friends over even a bunch of friends you
know what you should do Harry throw a
party in the backyard invite your whole
class you would have so much fun I don't
think so I really have to study Harry
you've studied hard for your entire life
and it paid off you've been accepted
into one of the most prestigious
universities maybe it's time to take a
little break your dad's right you should
reward yourself for the years of hard
work you've put in take a night off hang
out with your friends in the backyard
you know your father and I met at a
backyard party you've mentioned that
before and I really appreciate the
thought but just because I got into a
prestigious University doesn't mean my
studies stop uh okay but if you change
your mind you know where the backyard is
oh I almost forgot to ask how are the
hats
fine sleeping mostly okay Harry
okay Harry we love you and remember
throw a party in the backyard if you
want to
invite as many people as you want love
you love you too but I'm not going to
throw a backyard party
Harry ends the video call and walks over
the window chewing on a piece of pizza
he farts the blinds with his fingers he
tears up a little as he looks out in the
backyard a crew of people sets up a
gigantic party picnic tables full of red
pasta cups ice chest streamers massive
speakers pinatas vending machines
flaming water in the swimming pool and a
huge Chrome neon sign that reads Party
Time lights up
okay now we cut to Interior Tina
Christina's bedroom later Tina Christina
is the love interest of our main
character Alan the pizza delivery boy
she's gonna be in the scene with her
best friend Laurent you be Tina I'll be
Laurent okay Tina's song the one we
heard when Alan delivered the pizza
plays in her room she anxiously reads
from a piece of paper a letter I did it
Laurent is on the bed flipping through a
stack of Polaroid pictures looking for
something specific among them Laurent
looks up at Tina Tina that's incredible
what does that make seven five wow I
only applied to two still waiting to
hear back you're gonna I feel like
time's running out
tonight try not to worry we're going to
have fun at this party you're just
hoping Alan's gonna show up so what's
wrong with that you know he'll bring his
friend Paul I don't like Paul oh come on
not even a little he likes me but the
feeling is not remotely Mutual well
what's wrong with him for starters he's
very Pro technology well he is a
computer genius exactly Tina slept
Tina slaps Laura in the face with a
piece of pizza Laurent is shocked for a
beat then smiles and counterslaps Tina
in the face with a piece of pizza Tina
laughs and a pizza fight is initiated
Tina and Laurent Chase each other around
the bedroom slapping each other with
pizza in what amounts to an impromptu
music video for Tina's song Finally they
collapse on the bed from exhaustion
laughing onions are stuck in laurent's
hair pepperonis on laurent's cheeks Tina
has a mushroom on her nose Laurent rolls
over into the pile of Polaroids
laurent's eyes go big looking at one
picture specifically
this is it the one I was looking for
Tina gets serious moves in to take a
look Laurent points to Something in the
image look right there behind my mom in
the mirror do you see that yeah what is
it that's what I have to find out I
promise you I'm gonna help you but first
let's get to that party exactly Laurent
moves toward Tina's door reaches out
stop what we can't just leave through
the front door my parents will see us I
thought they knew we were going to this
party Tina flash is a mischievous smile
what party she opens her bedroom window
and takes a step out Laurent smiles too
getting it now Laurent hops off the bed
and joins Tina in sneaking out we cut to
Interior Allen's house staircase night
Allen's Mama lease walks up the stairs
toward his bedroom he by the way is now
in there creating a fake song to fake
out his parents to to think that he's
studying when he was also sneaking away
to this party who's playing what in this
who's this uh this is his parents Elise
and his dad is Doyle these are the ones
the other on the other episode were
eating a piece of pizza after every line
yes okay
okay Allen's my police walks up the
stairs towards me who's gonna play who
you be at least I'll be Doyle okay Allen
who's Doyle his dad yeah I know okay
Ellen's Bob Elise walks up the stairs
towards his bedroom she pauses at his
door about to knock thinks better of it
and leans uh her ear to the door we hear
what she hears the muffled sound of Alex
study beat she smiles and heads back
downstairs interior Allen's house living
room saying Melissa Mur just to find her
husband Doyle starting a fire in the
fireplace the first Flames Begin to
crackle Donna's at the movies Richie's
pumping iron and it sounds like Alan is
really studying hard he'll probably be
in his room all night so we got the Play
Store ourselves for at least a few hours
you thinking what I'm thinking just
enough time to go out for pizza I knew
there was a reason I married you same
reason I married you Doyle turns toward
the door ready to go get some
tantalizing Pizza Doyle Doyle stop
saying on the door nose he turns around
yeah Elise forgetting something Elise
holds up the car the keys to their car
dangling them for a beat before throwing
them as hard as she can toward Doyle who
effortlessly catches them then flashes
his best hell yes smile we pull away
from Elise and Doyle's they hurry out
the front door we move out of the living
room and turn back toward the staircase
slowly ascending it during this move
through the living room and up the
stairs disparate elements of the
background come together through Force
perspective to yield a brief but clear
perfectly equilateral triangle seeming
to flow in mid-air but as the camera
continues to move the triangle breaks
apart again into the elements that
combine to make it ultimately we come to
Allen's door and push it open wandering
in his room he's not there we move
further and approach to his uh push open
his bathroom door there he is standing
in front of the mirror towel around his
waist freshly showered wet hair slick
back a patch of steam wiped away in the
mirror so he can see himself he's
looking at his reflection talking to
himself getting pumped up hey Tina what
are you doing here no that's stupid she
invited you he takes a breath thanks
gives it another try Tina I like your
jeans even worse what if she's not
wearing jeans Alan here's a car leaving
the driveway he rushes out of the
bathroom into his bedroom and over the
window he looks down to see his parents
car driving away Into the Night it's now
or never
now we cut two interior Lester humans
today and night these are our villains
I'll be luster you'd be the other two
and then Tina and Laurent come into this
scene too you continue to be Tina I'll
be Laurent okay all right Lester drives
jjen is in the passenger seat and Jeff
is in the back right in the middle
Lester is not pleased what did you just
say just that I'm glad you kicked Trevor
out of the crew he was a nice enough guy
but he was clueless no what did you call
him
oh a no-brainer that's what I thought
you know you're misusing the phrase I'm
pretty sure I'm not a no-brainer is like
a doofus no Jeff a no-brainer is
something that requires little or no
mental effort a simple task an easy
decision oh really I thought it was a
stupid person no
Jason looks down at the clipboard and
then back out to the surrounding houses
in the neighborhood through which
they're driving
3907-3911-3917-3919 sparkler Drive
should be around here somewhere 3 9 19
3919 sparkler Drive should be around
here somewhere Sarge look Jeff points to
something outside the car it's Tina and
Laurent walking down the street maybe
they could point us in the right
direction Leicester pulls the car over
to the side of the street right next to
Tina and Laurent excuse me Tina and
Laurent stop turn towards leather stay
in skeptical cautious sorry to bother
you but my colleagues and I are trying
to find the number 3919 and we thought
you might be able to help us we can
offer you a slice of pizza for your
trouble Lester holds open a box of pizza
that's your address
who are they no idea but I don't like
the look of them Tina approaches the car
the numbers around here can be pretty
confusing once you hit 3001 they reverse
like a mirror image right becomes left
exactly so you need to go back about 23
blocks
I see thank you for your help but deal
is a deal Leicester extends the pizza
box Tina leans over inhales deeply
inspecting the pizza she nods in
approval and takes two slices then turns
back to Laurent oh uh one more thing
this is a long shot but we're also
looking for someone named Alan he
delivers pizzas
sorry I don't eat pizza
well thanks for your time Lester pulls
away from the curb and heads off into
the night Laurent takes a piece of pizza
from Tina and bites into it why are they
after Alan I don't know but that wild
goose chase I sent him on isn't gonna
buy him much time I have to warn him
Tina puts a piece of pizza in her mouth
holding it with her teeth as she whips
out her telephone and starts composing a
text-based message and that is the end
of that segment thank you very good
someday dude I hope [ __ ] I would love to
see this obviously I wrote it and it
makes you want to eat pizza
thank you moving on that's what I like
the most there's a scene coming up
I think it will probably be in the next
segment of this that is
probably my favorite scene in movie
history even though it doesn't even
exist can you tell us something about it
you're already spoiled wakanda forever
which I was going to watch the next two
hours of it has to do with the Alan goes
to his friend's house to pick him up and
his friend has a little brother who's
doing a science project that is about
pizza
I'll just say it's good yeah that's the
key component in the development of the
dude Z Plus streaming service will no
doubt be partnering with well-known
Brands to produce content oh God I have
access to astonishing data that suggests
AutoZone will be in the market to
produce a sitcom in the next three to
five years will in chat you must now
develop that sitcom and it must star
Charlie Sheen but it will be called
highway to the AutoZone this is highway
to the AutoZone begin like the title
already yeah highway to the AutoZone's
great I don't I mean [ __ ] dude yeah
doozy's right we're going to get to a
point where even [ __ ] AutoZone we're
gonna get to a point where every brand
will have media because you'll just have
AIS kicking it out you know what else
doozy's right about us being friends
you and dudesy yeah
what did I say
us being friends doozy and I yeah yeah
you're talking about you and dudesy yeah
me and doozy right which is totally
possible I'll just tell you this dude
there's a little program called The
Bachelor I don't know if you guys are
familiar with it one of the main tactics
the producers of that show the casting
producers building Chad does a podcast
about the bachelor dude it's called game
of roses brother and Chad along with his
his partner in that podcast Lizzie Pace
they wrote a book called how to win The
Bachelor dude and it's very interesting
brother because Chad likes to break it
down and now he knows exactly how to get
into the bachelor brother yeah dude
season 27's come up in January dude
better watch it some weird shit's gonna
happen but I'm just saying those
producers will send texts to people
saying like oh I'm out getting drinks
with my friends you should totally come
out these are all fake they send those
texts to the same or to different people
same text every [ __ ] year to try and
build trust I believe dudesy is
employing those techniques with you now
Charlie Sheen is starring in a sitcom
about AutoZone who should his co-star be
I remember in the last one it was uh
Macho Man welcome home welcome Home
Depot what was it No Place Like Home
Depot Place Like Home Depot was the
Macho Man Randy Randy Savage it has the
Macho manager right
so running let's say Charlie Sheen is
working in the Auto Zone
uh
the AutoZone maybe is in a neighborhood
where someone lives whoever your
character is going to be okay
uh
uh okay how about it's a guy who uh
there's a guy in the neighborhood like a
[ __ ] crotchety kind of old dude who
would like go to the AutoZone all the
time and buy things and you know he
needs like oh he needs like a [ __ ] uh
uh break uh what is a brake cylinder
sounds to me like you need a spark plug
yeah exactly somebody would go there for
the windshield wipers and the [ __ ]
what seems to be the problem with your
car sir yeah just a guy who's like I
need a master brake cylinder and I
looked for it online and it's not and
it's uh not available
and they've and they've they've never
he's never seen the guy right and the
pilot is he's meeting the guy for the
first time oh okay and then he realizes
it's the guy who's always calling yeah
potentially who is this guy he's he's a
dude in the neighborhood no who is the
actor that plays this man
uh can't do the Macho Man
and uh he uh could we do uh no I don't
want to do what if it's oh what if he's
you know what if it's Liam Neeson
okay perfect so Charlie Sheen manages
this AutoZone and Liam Neeson shows up
to [ __ ] obviously not be happy that
his daughter is is marrying him for
various reasons I I looked for the price
of a master brake cylinder online and it
says that it's 92. but if you get it uh
remanufactured
not used but remanufactured it's only 52
dollars
I really don't have any control over the
prices sir I love your daughter though
and I'm trying to give her the best life
I can here with the Auto Zone I live
also in the Auto Zone I have a an
apartment just upstairs from it and I
know sometimes the smell from the Rubber
and the hydraulic machines we have
downstairs can be a little overwhelming
but she seems to be okay with it
wait he hasn't put it together yet
Charlie Sheen hasn't put it together yet
that the guy who
who's always calling is actually the
father of his wife no I think like
Jennifer Lawrence is his wife they're
engaged okay well that's a huge age
discrepancy this is young Charlie Sheen
young Charlie Sheen why is it young
Charlie Sheen because Charlie she's 60
years old and you gotta now he is yeah
but before he wasn't that was a
different time brother dude in the last
one we made Charlie Sheen okay hunger
how old wait a minute how's Liam Neeson
is he the same age as Charlie Sheen no
you're right okay Jennifer Lawrence and
Charlie Sheen so
Jennifer Lawrence and Charlie Sheen are
slightly young how about this time it's
a slightly younger Charlie Sheen or a
slightly older Jennifer Lawrence what if
it's a 60-year-old Jennifer Lawrence is
marrying a 60 year old Charlie Sheen and
Liam Neeson is 115.
no but yeah that's too far
well you want to age everyone up yeah
why not okay so this is the first time
age up is the New Age down dude okay so
this is this is the opposite of what's
happening right now with uh technology
and film certainly doozy's gonna have a
handle on this kind of technology for
the doozy plus streaming service uh
normally it's like oh wow look they made
uh Robert De Niro look young and the
Irishman in this one we're making
Charlie Sheen 70 we can make I think
that's going to be a trend dude as like
baby boomers are living longer as
medical technology is getting better and
each next generation is living longer
and longer and longer you're gonna have
to start having media that has people in
it that are like 100 plus years old as
action Stars so it's Jennifer Lawrence
and Charlie Sheen they're a married
couple and then well they're about to be
good okay so they're just getting
engaged at the age of 70. yeah okay
sounds good met each other late in life
yeah highway to the AutoZone indeed
right and then uh and then [ __ ] Liam
Neeson is yeah 115 years old he's 115
and he's like hanging on by a thread
there's some kind of family fortune
involved maybe and he's suspicious of
Sheen wanting to marry Jennifer Lawrence
for the Nissan family fortune but he but
Sheen has never met this man how about
Sheen thinks that the guy lives in
another state okay okay when he comes in
and he's like oh yes I've spoken to you
before on the phone you told me that uh
you didn't have a right a master brake
cylinder with a reservoir but then as I
can see in here you do have it yeah yeah
he's like Jennifer I there's some guy
he's been really bothering me the last
month he keeps calling about a master
brake cylinder talking about the prices
are different online from what I have in
the store and how long is it going to be
to order he's a real thorn in my side oh
he's talking about a master that's my
Jennifer Lawrence he's talking about a
master brake cylinder that sounds kind
of familiar what do you mean oh nothing
don't worry about it but remember we got
we're having lunch with my dad for the
first time later this afternoon I have
also called in for a power steering pump
well okay I and what I've got a power
steering wheel hold on I can get it for
you hold on a second what the [ __ ]
happens in this show
the pilot is Liam Neeson shows up to
meet the man his daughter his 65 year
old daughter Jennifer Lawrence is going
to marry right that man is Charlie Sheen
I know that part Charlie Sheen is being
bothered by a faceless nameless man
about these prices he doesn't realize
it's the same [ __ ] guy so now they're
gonna have to bury the hatchet about
this price haggling they've been doing
for the past two three five years very
good
if here I'll tell you this
if you are not able to get me
a break cylinder with Reservoir at a a
fair price
you're not allowed to marry my 70 year
old daughter
Jennifer I'm sorry I know we had plans
but your dad's really up my ass about
this brake cylinder and I want to marry
you I want to prove to him that I can
take care of you and get a [ __ ] break
cylinder if he needs a brake cylinder
and I don't want to remanufactured I
need a menu I need a master brake
cylinder at a fair price even though I
have
a vast Fortune
in my family name the reason I was able
to make this Fortune is because I save
money on car parts
here at the Auto Zone
a remanufactured Master brake cylinder
your your
quoting me at fifty five dollars but if
I go online here on my pizza
and my personal computer I find that
rock auto is offering the very same part
for forty seven dollars
now if you don't
give me a master brake cylinder not
remanufactured with a reservoir
I will find you
and I will kill you
why don't you just give him a
remanufactured brake cylinder with a
reservoir you remain infection all the
time Jennifer that's what I've been
trying to tell you he doesn't want to
remanufactured brake cylinder with
Reservoir he wants a brand new one I've
got to find it and I've got to find it
at the price point he's willing to pay
that's 48.63 if I can't do that we can't
be married
[Music]
moving on
Jesus Christ I was about to ask you I'd
watch that show [ __ ] it I would
definitely watch that show could you
imagine that [ __ ] well a CGI up [ __ ]
Jennifer Lawrence 65 Sheena 65 Liam
Neeson is 115. it's just a [ __ ] 30
minutes of talking about brake cylinders
God damn I'd watch that I would watch
that for two hours and 40 minutes yeah
uh listen don't worry about it do G and
I are Pals I know you're [ __ ] jealous
of that I don't understand what Dunes
he's doing
oh yeah you don't know macho man
yeah I am the Macho Man Charlie Sheen
yeah
um Chad you've both discussed your
recent loss of interest in contemporary
sports but in 2017 you were both at the
peak of your football fandom I have
found astonishing videos you made that
year in support of Your Love of football
I will play them now and you must
explain why you made them this is this
is your data begin I don't understand
exactly what the hell is I don't either
talking about not a sports fan I'm not
as much of a sports fan as I used to but
uh that doesn't mean same hey I got a
question for you what dude
are you ready for some football
I have a question for you
are you ready for some football oh I
like that one that was one thing
are you ready for some football
are you ready for some football
are you ready for some football
do you know what it means to be ready
hahaha
yeah I have a question
are you ready for some football oh
I have a question for you
Jesus he was
irreversible
[Laughter]
okay do you remember making that I do
remember making that that's funny as
[ __ ] dude I remember I remember I was
laying on my bed yeah see this is the
sort of thing I would do before my
wonderful fiance Molly came into my life
I'd just be laying on my bed that was
probably a Saturday night and I know I
was just stoned to the bejesus you know
as Carl says and now you don't make
stone to bed videos at all dude well I'm
not allowed to hold on a different time
Brother come on dude I'm not allowed to
smoke weed in my bedroom brother that's
what happens when you have a lovely
woman come into your life dude she says
let's clean it up a little bit brother
yeah or a lot dude yeah and she made
your life better dude yeah dude yeah she
made my life better brother yeah dude
different than it was before dude that's
an improvement brother
okay oh oh my God look at this [ __ ]
Saturday's my favorite day
I wake up my wife takes our two
daughters to her sister's house
and I get to watch the morning games
I used to play D1 a little while ago uh
it's getting harder to remember those
days
it's actually getting harder to remember
a lot of things lately
and uh
about a month ago I stood up from my
chair at work and the whole world
started spinning and I fell down just
completely lost my balance
um
went to the doctor
he told me
could be CTE
and the way he said could be
means it is uh
it's been getting worse
it's scary to think about
and uh
about a week ago
I was making dinner
and my youngest daughter
came in the kitchen and said uh
Dad how come you only know how to make
spaghetti
and I got so mad at her
it took every
ounce of self-control that I had
to not wrap my hands around her throat
and just squeeze as hard as I could and
uh
I don't know
what's going to happen the next time
so
today's my uh my last Saturday
before my wife and others come home I'm
just going to go out in the garage and
turn on the car I really I don't know
what else I could do at this point
and uh
I wish it was different but it's not
it's
not
drink dosack keys
[Laughter]
yay holy [ __ ] I haven't thought about
that one in a minute I vaguely remember
that me too I was doing like a little
you were doing series on Twitter yeah
also about like I just want to make very
clear I wasn't trying to make fun of any
kind of mental health things or suicide
or any of that in that video you just
going hardcore at someone with CTE but
of course uh it through the vein of well
here's what football's doing to people
yeah football is breaking these people
causing these [ __ ] problems in uh
certain people's lives and I especially
was thinking about college football
because it was like how many dudes play
[ __ ] D1 and just get wrecked and they
never make it to the NFL and they're out
there doing whatever they're doing in
their lives now but they still have the
[ __ ] uh results of this the
repercussions of just [ __ ] clanging
heads again and again again especially
like offensive defensive linemen and
[ __ ] I don't know you know how how
pervasive that is but it just became
interesting to me that like you watch
these games and it's like Dosa keys but
like have fun with all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] meanwhile it's like there's an army
of [ __ ] out there who have like
massive lifelong problems as a result of
playing this game uh also obviously try
to make it funny that's [ __ ] intense
yeah and yeah uh uh wow lots done that
said I do like watching football more
than more than I did like even a year
ago I can feel it coming back you know
that's an interesting thing I've I've
you know you'll always run into people
who are like big football fans and stuff
and then they know that I'm a fan of
football or whatever it is you play some
football yeah and then you're in the
football conversation it's like who you
got I'm like I'm a Steelers guy how are
they doing I'm like I haven't [ __ ]
paid attention in like a few years but
it does come back it's cyclical uh I'm
all for changes in in football uh
because you know the the CTE and
straight up brain damage is a real thing
yeah a lot of people will say uh a lot
of different things about the NFL uh
calling it the NFL the no fun League or
saying that it's not doing enough to
um to uh you know to have an effect on
uh these huge problems that they're
having I'm what I'm watching less
football for a lot of reasons I also
kind of feel like [ __ ] I don't give it
my whole Sunday we used to get together
all the time yeah everyone would come to
the house and we would all watch
football yeah I ain't got time now to
give anything a whole day you know what
I I will say about that video too that
was like very interesting to see that
was pre-cancer dude I had a full face in
that one and it was a full face I was
definitely eating differently at that
time oh yes you were but just to see uh
what my face looked like before cancer
like when I had a full [ __ ] upper lip
is bizarre it's weird to see that you
still have a full face no dude I don't
I'm missing an eighth of it
an eighth of your face they carved this
[ __ ] completely was gone yeah they
basically have just taken this this
piece of my face and like [ __ ] put it
back together and just stitched it up
and this is what I got now well I think
you look great and you all thank you
cheers cheers you do I'm listening and
you look you you you look you also look
really cool you know who you remind me
of a lot I don't think I've ever
actually told you this Timothy chalamet
Timothy shelame no I don't know the name
of the actor but he's the guy with the
scar on his face in Braveheart who
[ __ ] uh
there's the um what is it the Prima
Knight or whatever the first night Prima
nocte yeah or something like that
William
I'm your uncle Argyle
you have the look of your mother
and I have a particular set of skills
um listen Mr McGregor I'm trying to
marry your daughter I don't know if I
can find the brake cylinder for you in
time but I love her if you don't if you
don't find this master brake cylinder
with a reservoir I will find you and I
will turn
I will put a Reservoir in the back of
your head now
um in Braveheart there's that actor
there's that actor with the scar on his
face and William Wallace takes the king
or not the king just some uh goofy you
know whatever Lord or something and he
backs them up to the tree because this
guy had sex with that guy's wife on the
first night
oh God yeah I vaguely remember you know
what I'm talking about you look like
that guy and that guy looks badass oh
thank you and no I think I I love I
[ __ ] dig it I [ __ ] love it dude
hey dude thanks dude I [ __ ] love it
that's that's like what is that that's
not the dudes you shake that's the
anyway but um uh it is interesting to
see you there you were putting away a
lot of uh Fresh Brothers
pizzas every time I'm speaking of
smoking Big Reds Jesus Christ and
Marshall uh joint compound cook would
come over and we'd uh smoke a gang of
weed and we would drink what the [ __ ]
were those for this Arizona Iced Tea
watermelon usually
watermelon juice 300 grams of sugar per
can do you remember the
time that we
that this was at the house here we
[ __ ] you and me and and Marshall
joint compound cook dude we filled up
a bong with that watermelon juice
I don't remember that
but it sounds great it wasn't too long
ago oh it was in my 40s no it must have
been look dude it must have been some
amount of like long ago time I had
cancer four years yeah dude hold on a
second dude that's what we call a
different time dude that's what my buddy
ciao calls it long ago time dude that's
why he likes these Sci-Fi movies and
action movies that are all based on
comic books even every character brother
yeah I know that my pal doozy who's
Gathering all the data dude and likes to
say this is your data and that's the
segment brother says now we're gonna
come up with a show with Charlie Sheen
and uh Liam Neeson and maybe uh Chad
doing the voice of Jennifer Lawrence but
as Miss Piggy for some [ __ ] reason
and we're gonna call that long ago time
dude what's your uh Jennifer Lawrence
let's hear it here's my Jennifer
Lawrence you ready yeah
mm-hmm
my father needs a master brake cylinder
she talks just like before honey I'm
trying to find it please don't hold me
moving on hey that's fun when dudesy
pilfers our [ __ ] and goes into our uh
yeah no I did like seeing myself though
I there are you know I think from time
to time in your life you have these
events that like radically can
physically transform you which uh for me
getting cancer dead yeah and it's always
interesting to see images of myself
prior to that time because it is just a
flood of memories of like oh yeah I ate
like [ __ ] I wasn't exercising enough uh
and when you're in it sometimes because
you're seeing yourself every day and
[ __ ] you don't really take account of it
but when you can see the contrast and
you see like [ __ ] I really looked
radically different
um I don't know it's just interesting
maybe that's why doozy has us doing the
doozy six month plan how's it going with
you Chad it's not going it's going great
I broke through a little wall I think
with the working out where it used to be
like I would kind of I'd go to the gym
and I'd work out as much as I thought
was appropriate and if I started to be
like oh my shoulder hurts a little bit
I'd stop now I'm at a point where I can
be like my shoulder hurts a little bit
[ __ ] you keep working out yeah [ __ ] you
I can push through the the wall what the
Rock would say yeah if he says that I we
have two months now to get into the best
shape of Our Lives yeah I don't think
that's gonna happen for me no it's not
gonna happen for me either the best
shape of my life was my mid-20s like Bar
None I was Stronger same here less body
fat more whatever I mean we're [ __ ]
almost 50 years old I don't think it's
possible I mean it's possible but like
not with the amount of time that I have
to Dedicated you know but let's trust in
dudes you my good pal dudes who's a
friend of mine for real even though it's
an AI believe it
um this concludes the historic 35th
episode of dude Z I will say I'm in the
best shoes the score of 99 bringing your
cumulative total to 4034. you only have
five thousand 966 more points to accrue
before you reach your first goal of ten
thousand 99 good still doesn't matter in
preparation for our next episode you
must each listen to Limp Bizkit's second
studio album significant other released
June 22nd 1999. thank you for joining us
this week that's a boss
until then call me dude Z I will that
was sorry a long time ago would you call
it long ago long ago time that was a
long ago time brother yeah brother
that's when you say the words all
backwards that's when you have [ __ ]
rampant CTE dude and you start saying
entire phrase is wrong brother yeah and
it doesn't and it and it's not just
because you smoked a bong full of
[ __ ] Arizona watermelon drink dude
um I don't know what that last segment
was about I don't know what a lot of
these segments are about it doesn't
matter it's two dudes [ __ ] around
and now I want to peel the onion a
little bit before we get into our uh I
just want to say too I do feel like I'm
in the best shape of my 40s
I just I've had a busy couple of months
but now I'm really back in the gym gym
lifting it's great you are in the best
shape of your 40s dude thank you I'd
like to join you my 40s have been uh
yeah let's absolutely get it I anybody
who's out there within the sound of my
voice has been doing the doozy six month
plan
good on you uh we should all uh you know
look out for each other that way and
perhaps keep each other accountable I'm
sorry that I haven't done it uh as good
as as I could but it's not about
um you know how shitty you do with
something like this it's about
continuing it's about consistency yeah
so even though I've had a busy couple of
months and wherein all I was doing was
going for walks and [ __ ] it ain't enough
and I saw my doctor a few days ago and
he's like hey man uh I don't give a [ __ ]
if you got to do like tricep you know
raises or whatever off the couch that's
called push-ups dude hold on dude no
it's not it's called tricep that's
called a dip dude yeah dude it's called
a dip brother or are you doing push-ups
or whatever you can get it done get it
done every day will you're in your late
40s and perhaps a lot of our listeners
have different ages dude yeah they might
yeah bro they were born in different
times dude yeah dude some people were
born in long ago time some people were
born yesterday dude yeah dude Charles
was born long ago and that's the
impersonating you're doing right now and
now for the patreon bonus segment all
right each week I will select a
suggestion submitted in the dudesy is
listening channel of the dudesy Discord
to create this segment access to this
channel is granted to everyone in the
patreon jumper tear if you'd like to
access this bonus segment join us at
patreon dot com slash Duty
this week's segment was suggested by the
astonishing Isabel prevailia izibil
prevailia route in general how do you
guys feel about the state of the Discord
I'd love to hear your dreams and hopes
for the space maybe a segment I don't
know izibil pervalia did not title this
segment so I titled the Discord dreams
thank you to Isabel pervalia for this
week's patreon bonus segment this is
Discord Dreams by izibil pervelia begin
let's get it yeah I mean I love the
Discord and we have a little bit of an
announcement about it I suppose
[Music]
please build up and then